thank you so much for being here
we have something unusual we're going to
do right now we had a uh request from an
audience member
a jared agnetti are you here jared
jarrett would you like to you're
something you'd like to do is that right
jared that's correct okay
oh you're not going to physically harm
me are you
a lot of audience members want to do
that good to see you jared yeah no
problem where are you from jared uh
arizona you're from arizona okay and uh
you you come here to the show offers
this your first time to coming to a
taping first time first time coming
tipping okay and we just got a message
that you want to do something we don't
know what it is so
tell us what's up i'm not really sure
what's going on either
okay
well then that would be a huge waste of
all of our time wouldn't it jared
i can improvise though if you like yeah
okay why don't you want to hold the
microphone and sure sure
melissa milly
i have been in love with you from the
moment i've met you
you are the moon of my life
will you marry me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey nicely done
congratulations
[Applause]
okay who's next
let's do more of these that was
fantastic
guys you're getting nervous really
congratulations
and what's that we're all invited to the
wedding
seriously congratulations what is your
name melissa melissa okay that was very
cool wow i had no idea i didn't know
what was happening shaking
so we'll get you a copy of that thank
you yeah this is one of the services we
provide here at the show
yeah
when it's time for a baby christening
you can come here
that was really nice that was very sweet
that was really cool thanks a lot for
all
being here and that was the real show
tonight that was cool bye-bye everybody
bye
go jimmy go